l' affaire grégory encore et toujours
cette fois c'est la famille de bernard
laroche qui accuse le juge de partialité
depuis que jean marie villemin a été
remise en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire
je vous rappelle que jean marie villemin
a tué son cousin bernard laroche qu'il
soupçonnait d'avoir assassiné son fils
grégory isabelle beige clair dans les
vosges la libération de jean marie
villemin
à la veille de noël n'allait pas passer
son protestation on s'en doutait après
le choc des premiers jours aujourd'hui
la famille de bernard laroche a battu
voilà deux ans et demi par son cousin la
famille de la victime donc se mobilisent
contre la décision de la cour d'appel et
accuse le juge simon de partialité
y a pas de justice en france on y croit
plus obligés de qi croix du la
libération jean marie villemin nice en
compte six
s'ils se présentent dans les vosges
automatiquement sûr il faut faire
quelque chose
enfin le premier pas à lui demande pas
de venir nous on ira posant de lui mais
si lui vient ou vendus au rang de nous
on sera là tu te sens des paroles qui ne
vont pas dans le sens de l'apaisement
mais les juges ont pris leurs
précautions
l'assassin de bernard laroche est
interdit de séjour dans les vosges sa
libération le remportant la vie de
couple avec sa femme christine toujours
inculpée d'infanticide une apparence de
bonheur retrouvé pour les villemin qui
est insupportable la roche
leurs avocats ont l'intention
d'introduire un recours en cassation
contre la mise en liberté de jean marie
villemin